comment fabriquer son propre gel
hydroalcoolique alors on à jean michel
cohen ici qui est une blouse blanche
voilà qu'on nous a d'ailleurs fait lever
la main comme ça where garde
l'organisation mondiale de la santé a
publié la fameuse recette pour faire
votre gel voilà comme ceci parce que
c'est vrai que ça coûte les yeux de la
tête en ce moment donc si vous avez
envie de le faire à la maison comment on
fait d'abord précision ça empêche pas du
tout de se laver les mains en fait le
gel hydroalcoolique
c'est un système qui permet de se
nettoyer les mains quand on est à
l'extérieur parce qu'à pas de lavabo et
c'est le lavage de mains avec le savon
ça reste quand même la première chose à
faire on va acheter des choses très très
simple l'alcool 166 et la bloque
c'est d'accord qu'on achète mon
pharmacien oui on peut acheter de
l'alcool au travail parce qu'on vous
demande si on l'achète chez nicolas les
étiquettes là pour vous la voyez on met
de l'alcool 166 militants ensuite on va
mettre de l'eau oxygénée
alors il y avait un début donc lotigié
on entre on peut la trouver chez le
pharmacien également longtemps donné et
les coiffeurs savent très bien
l'utiliser
alors on dit que c'est une saveur on
peut demander de l'oxygène et oui il en
aurait coloré c'est les coiffeurs vont
dire que c'est à des discours sensé à
dix volumes et chez le pharmacien il
faudra dire que c'est à 3%
donc c'est la différence on va mélanger
1 mais justin t on à 8,4 millilitres
remettent les chiens passent devant sa
fiche alors très bien à oued accord en
suis tombé contre 80 m de la glycérine
ça va donner un côté un peu vis
coproduit donc ça va permettre à
l'alcool et à l'eau oxygénée d'être
efficace enfin on a mis lui aussi trois
militants du var matin on se trompe
enfin will elle a raison ça se trouve
vous lasser des produits en pharmacie
toujours produit extrêmement simple on
en vient presque à l'arrivée ça va nous
coûter plus cher qu'un gène c'est quoi
[Applaudissements]
d'abord parce que le prix de ces gels a
augmenté de façon fine donc il ya eu une
régulation qui s'est faite
et la deuxième chose c'est qu'il ya
surtout des ruptures de stock alors ils
d'accord donc et ensuite on a rajouté de
la flotte tout simplement sa salle au
nom pas là on en trouve on en trouve
dans le comptable et on va tous y est
bon on va juste mélangez le avec le
fasse oui je préfère je me posais une
question en attendant parce que oui
parce que vous venez de huit années de
chimistes ces deux là ne sont pas
débloqués marche pas ne sera pas aussi
efficace et là on fait des huit sections
ça commence à mousser et ça c'est quoi
le dernier truc c'est parce que tabasco
ça sent pas bon
vous aimez vous avez leur permettre la
recette auprès du tas vannerie set et
ensuite on va on rajoute à un arôme ou
enfin là on a qui déduit des entreprises
éléments et on met un peu d'huile
essentielle alors le truc qu'il faut
faire si c'est que cyril tu peux remet
pendant 72 heures encore parce qu'en
fait il faut le laisser reposer en fait
la solution d'accès voilà quand tu vas
faire le show non il faut le laisser
reposer 72 heures parce qu'il doit y
avoir des traces de microbes ont été
introduites au moment où on a fait toute
cette manipulation et pendant ces 72
heures
grâce à ce mélange ça va s'éliminer on
va pouvoir en avoir conservé au frais
non non on peut le conserver à
température ambiante
et l'autre à cavaillon défaite attendue
sur que jeunesse et des enfants c'est le
fils d'un médecin quand même c'est vrai
qu'on perd en sortant pour raconter
l'histoire comment t'as fait mélange de
ça non mais quoi c'est bien fait
l'animateur les chéris je voudrais vous
dire ça fait attention les 10 s'est pas
portée des enfants soient réunies
jusqu'à d'alcool tout ça un jour me
voilà non seulement pas le mettre à
levante ensuite pas ce sens m sur les
une fois ils avaient cessé dans la main
et faites attention à vos animaux
voilà mais c'est un système qui vous
permet d'avoir votre petite préparation
et on tournait avec